der normale menschen benutzen auch ein
löffel dafür das passiert jedes mal was
geht ab willkommen bei einem kann zumal
mit der kamera dann sind mit genehmen
wir die gegend nicht fangen wir an und
du gehst wasser und dann aber das will
doch sogar eingeschnitten eigentlich was
gedacht und herzlich willkommen bei
video ja ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt
gut
ja ja was machen heute ihr habt haben
diese schon gelesen
heute kommt eine neue bad meines format
ich teste die neuesten trends aus
2009/10 es kann ja bis jetzt schon
generell das neueste essen dann gab es
auf die neuesten getränke also alles
sachen die im jahr 2019 gelaunt stören
beziehungsweise auf den markt kommen
ich muss bei dieser sache und auch bei
dieser sache sagen komischerweise die
schmecken an ungefähr ähnlich weil ich
bin immer wieder überrascht wenn man
sich da so ein bisschen 30 mal wie viele
neue sachen das tagtäglich in
supermärkten gibt getränke und essen
gehen dann haben wir gemacht verlinkt
ich euch in der video beschreibung
könnte auf euch nach dem video anschauen
und heute habt ihr euch gewünscht die
neuesten süßigkeiten trends aus 2009 10
ich wollte mal einkaufen und ich würde
sagen ich kann euch direkt mal die
produkte zeigen es sind insgesamt acht
geworden aber so das heißt wollte wie
jetzt wieder ein bisschen ungesünder
aber mein körper kann das total ab immer
wenn ich die kommentare der sieger alex
du warst doch weil die arbeit ist und so
macht euch keine sorgen mir geht es gut
irgendwie sieht das volk nicht aus aber
ich muss vergessen hatte ok dann will
ich gar nicht sagen aber wir starten mit
joghurt weil dann kann ich hier wieder
den kühlschrank stellen
der ist irgendwie echt nur ich bin euch
hier mal das produkt wurde davon ein
monten ich creme würde ich mal gespannt
was da jetzt an den anderen irgendwie
kommt nichts raus
der normale menschen benutzen auch ein
löffel dafür jedes mal
[Musik]
ja gut also an sich jetzt nicht
überraschend ist das schmeckt einfach
wie dieser monte joghurt ohne schokolade
drin also das steht monte milch eben
drauf spreche halt auch nach mainstream
ist in ordnung kann man essen recht von
mir wie er war lieb gemeinte die sagen
jetzt bei shopping man dieses meine
mutter ob das immer kriegt von mir mal
wieder lieb gemeinte 7 punkte auf diese
hier freue ich mich ganz besonders ich
bin immer noch ein richtiger lions can
also wenn man mal so entspannt auto
fährt autobahnraststätte hole ich mir
sehr sehr oft einfach so einen kaffee
und dazu noch einen laien und die haben
ein neues produkt ausgebracht leyen
peanut wild und ich muss sagen die
verpackung finde ich fühle mich jetzt
wie so ein krasser produkttest haben
wird werde ich gar nicht sein aber gebt
euch mal die verpackung finde ich übelst
nice und kümmern dann hier der regel
also natürlich man doch schon richtig
hunger raus das ist dann das dinge
probieren wir mal schnell
guck mal so sieht das aus also da sind
halt gegen wieso große streusel drauf
komme ich spreche jetzt mal langsam auf
wie in der werbung
[Musik]
meine werbung sieht irgendwie besser aus
oder wir uns gerade ein bisschen über
den letzten schott amüsiert ich habe
schon einmal abgerissen aber irgendwie
habe ich total vergessen darauf zu
achten wie es schmeckt deswegen ein
sondern sie ist auf jeden fall länger
ich würde jetzt aber nicht sagen dass es
besser schmeckt als die normale variante
davon weil die finde ich irgendwie
nochmal besser
das kann man auf jeden fall es nicht
schlecht ist es nicht aber voll und
jetzt auch nicht deswegen auch hier
liebt geweihte sieben von zehn punkte
also ich muss sagen es ist extrem
chocolat ich wollte ich hätte auch mal
so ein bisschen nach gummibärchen oder
sie schauen können wir machen aber
weiter hat wird nach sache die ich
irgendwie voll spontan gekauft habt und
zwar habe ich diese beiden sachen nur
gekauft ich war immer so wo diese ganzen
sachen stehen dann stand halt oben you
drauf und das war halt auch so
gekennzeichnet in der reihe
dann habe ich das mitgenommen und genau
das gleiche wahrheit auch in der
abteilung und da habe ich halt diese
hier mitgenommen und habe erst zu hause
gemerkt dass sie absolut gleich aussehen
also wir haben hier eine kooperation
zwischen orior will kann auch sein dass
mittlerweile zu meter gehört ich will
jetzt auch gar nichts falsches sagen man
sieht halt nur ganz klar dass das
absolut dasselbe ist ich würde sagen ich
probiere jetzt einfach mal beides und
sagt dann erst mal wie es schmeckt und
dann auf welches besser ist fangen wir
mal mit loriot an
[Musik]
das schmeckt wie diese quarks co kannst
du diese komplex die genauso aussah
leute wenn man dir so sieht das sieht
der extrem aus wie irgendwie so
cornflakes ich kommen hat nicht auf den
namen aber da kann man auch bestimmt
gutes müsli mitmachen kann man nicht
versucht immer aufzubrechen klappt super
also um es mal auf einem ergebnis zu
kommen ich finde beide in ordnung die
hier schmecken mir allerdings nicht so
gut kriegen von mir nur fünf von zehn
punkte und diese hier kriegen auch gut
gemeinte sieben punkte also wert heute
wirklich noch nichts dabei was mich voll
umhaut vor allem die haben auch beide 1
euro 50 gekostet ist ja schon teuer für
sowas ist meine spieler sind da auch gar
nicht drin
es ist fast schon leer investiert euer
geld lieber in andere sei okay leute wir
machen weiter und haben hier nicht so
sauber wobei ich da graf ich schon
gemerkt hab ich schon locker fünf
minuten in dieser gummibärchen abteilung
und hab mich voll abgefuckt könnt ihr
das wenn ihr das steht und einfach so
ein stinknormales produkt sucht ist aber
nicht findet obwohl es da sein muss und
ich zeige euch das mal kurz bei haribo
sind vor einer woche oder so diese
gummibärchen rausgekommen haribo sauer
happy cherrys also von der verpackung ja
finde ich ist es absurd gleich zumindest
vom muster und so dann habe ich mich
gefreut geil du hast sie endlich
gefunden und dann hier festzustellen
nein ich habe sie nicht gefalle sowie
gibt es glaube ich schon deutlich länger
ich weiß nicht soll ich trotzdem
probieren ja am heftigsten ist immer gut
[Musik]
blau ist in ordnung nehme ich jetzt aber
aus der wertung gibt es halt schon
länger zählt nicht dazu aber kann man
essen
okay wir machen weiter das ist extrem
neu ich weiß nicht das gibt es wirklich
noch nicht lange ich würde auch sagen
höchstens 12 benutzer haben wir hier
prinzen rollen krimis kekse zerschmelzen
mit nuss nougat creme
also wenn ich da jetzt so reinschaut da
sind vielleicht zehn stück drin
[Musik]
leute also so sind die aus und zu diesem
hier ist das hütchen merkt ihr das ein
paar brocken schmeckt nach kriegsende
manchmal ist das so schwer zu bewerten
das sind einfach ganz normale pixel ich
habe ich schon 20.000 mal in meinem
leben gegessen nicht so ihr habt einen
keks dazwischen bisschen schokolade und
obendrüber noch im kleineren krebs dann
habt ihr genau dieses produkt ist ja
auch prinzenrolle hört ja ich weiß aber
es ist ja jetzt nichts neues
außergewöhnliches da hätten also klar
das sieht ein bisschen anders aus aber
schmeckt eins zu eins wieder rest davon
also wie diese ganz typischen rollen die
so hoch sind besser trotzdem natürlich
jetzt auch nicht schlecht aber ich freue
mich dann auch wenn man mal irgendwas
hat was wirklich komplett gegen die neu
ist und darum bat und das haut mich auch
wieder nicht und deswegen haben wir hier
auf lieb gemeinte sieben von zehn punkte
habe ich heute eigentlich irgendwann
auch mal nicht sieben von zehn punkten
geben dann kriegt es nur sechs leute und
eine neue sache haben wir noch und zwar
dass hier
da muss ich erst mal kurz eine kleine
story zu erzählen und zwar kann ich mich
daran erinnern
früher habe ich mir immer nach dem
fußballtraining weil da war sondern
tankstelle gegenüber so ein schokoriegel
geholt der hieß mister tom ich bin euch
den hier mal ein und ich habe es eben
genau das ihr werk einfach nur ein neues
produkt dieser marke nur das ding heißt
ja mister jim man muss aber sagen die
verpackung ist eins zu eins gleich und
ob das jetzt dazu gehört oder nicht das
weiß ich gar nicht kennst du das
misstrauen der druckt orange-roten das
sieht doch genauso aus oder
also wenn das nicht irgendwie zusammen
gehört da weiß ich auch nicht
fällt etwa der härteste weg nach unten
das ist eine extreme naja also dieses
muster tag früher gefeiert ja immer nach
dem fußballtraining erst mal ein pferd
ein schokoriegel auf jeden fall sehr
gesund das muss doch dazu gehören das
sind ja okay diese ganz normalen nüssel
wie man da auch hat weißt du bei diesem
muster tom dinge ich muss sagen also es
tut mir leid ich hoffe wie möglich dafür
trotzdem noch alles was wir heute haben
nichts davon hat mich umgehauen und das
ist ja echt schade also wie ich immer
sage ich möchte jetzt auch nicht
schlecht man kann es essen aber ich
würde es mir jetzt niemals holen wenn
ich sage jetzt habe ich aber gerade bock
auch für süßes ich weiß nicht also hier
auch lieb gemeinte 7 von 10 punkten es
mir nicht übel
schreibt mir super gerne gegen welche
sachen in die kommentare die neu sind
und gefeiert und auch immer sehr wichtig
wenn ihr dieses formats worten wollt
gebten daumen nach oben schreibt weitere
ideen weitere kategorien die ich machen
soll in die comments und das war es
eigentlich auch schon von mir
schaufenstern vorbei da ist ja alex w
wir sehen uns morgen wieder 19 uhr
jeden tag gibt es ein video und ja haut
rein aber nicht vergessen